В Україні достатньо лікарів у розрахунку на кількість населення,
запевняє виконувачка обов'язків міністра охорони здоров’я Уляна Супрун.
Разом з тим Україні нині, на її думку,
більше потрібні лікарі первинної ланки,
а не вузькоспеціалізовані фахівці.
В Україні є 185 тисяч лікарів, які є в реєстрі.
На наше населення це насправді достатня кількість.
DW вирішила перевірити:
Якщо поділити населення України на кількість лікарів,
озвучену Уляною Супрун,
отримуємо більше чотирьох медиків на тисячу українців.
Це навіть вище середнього показника у Євросоюзі.
Так, приміром, у Німеччині,
за даними Організації економічного співробітництва та розвитку,
теж трохи більше 4 лікарів на тисячу населення,
у Франції - 3,4.
Водночас, найменше медиків - у сусідній з Україною Польщі - 2,4.
Утім, кількість фахівців не завжди означає якість.
Щороку в Україні з медичних вишів
випускаються близько 10 тисяч новоспечених лікарів.
Часто це студенти платної форми навчання,
які отримували свої дипломи незалежно від успішності.
Так само не сприяє успішності майбутніх лікарів
і тотальна корупція у деяких медичних вишах.
Усе це призводить до низької довіри до медиків серед населення.
За даними опитування, проведеного соціологічною групою "Рейтинг"
наприкінці минулого року,
лише 4% українців оцінюють
рівень компетентності лікарів як дуже високий.
Тоді як більшість респондентів все ж таки
до української медицини скептичні:
ільше половини опитаних вважають
професіоналізм українських лікарів низьким.
Тим часом високо кваліфіковані українські медики
або переходять працювати до приватних клінік,
чиї послуги доступні далеко не всім українцям,
або ж виїжджають за кордон,
оскільки не бачать для себе перспектив в Україні.
Найчастіше українські лікарі емігрують до Східної Європи:
Польщі, Угорщини та Чехії.
Тамтешні фахівці виїздять до заможніших країн Євросоюзу
у пошуку кращих заробітків,
через що збільшується кількість вакансій у цих країнах.
Так само серед популярних напрямків працевлаштування
для українських медиків - Німеччина.
За даними Федеральної палати лікарів,
станом на кінець 2017 року у ФРН працювали
1485 медиків з України.
Як зізнаються самі лікарі, емігрують не лише через вищі зарплати,
а задля набуття нового досвіду і через вищий рівень життя.
Іще одна проблема медичних кадрів в Україні:
майже чверть лікарів - фахівці пенсійного віку.
До медичної реформи, яка нині проводиться в країні,
вони просто не готові,
негативно ставляться до змін та вдаються у своїй роботі
до звичних, проте застарілих методів лікування.
Дефіциту лікарів за чисельністю в Україні дійсно немає,
забезпеченість медиками в країні близька до середнього в Європі рівня.
Однак попри те, що в Україні щороку випускаються тисячі молодих фахівців,
рівень їхньої підготовки нерідко далекий від бажаного.
При цьому залишаються питання і до фахівців старшого покоління,
які отримували освіту ще за радянських часів.
Їхні методи лікування часто застарілі.
Тим часом високо кваліфіковані лікарі
через низький рівень зарплат і бажання самореалізації
нерідко виїжджають за кордон.